la majorité des gens y viennent il sera
prochainement assez pour dire un jour je
suis à côté du bled c'est certainement
le rapprochement entre les deux rives la
rive algérienne elle arrive de marseille
la nostalgie disparue depuis notre pays
de eto'o mais on se dit qu'on est
d'alger mais on n'a pas de terme et y
signer là bas
ouah
de neydens année
c'est un
et
eh ben
les achats plein de noblesse
et achats
oh
j'ai crié
à
et ça
c'est un lieu où se rencontre où ils
reçoivent un rayon du soleil
particulièrement au printemps
particulièrement un peu à l'approché de
l'hiver et c'est ça leur fait du bien
ils sont là assis en train de discuter
de papoter de se raconter des histoires
anciennes nouvelles et c'est si bon le
mot chibani indique un homme âgé un
homme qu'on doit respecter un homme sage
aujourd'hui
chibani évoque plutôt ses vieux
travailleurs immigrés
ce sont des gens etc c'est moi qui sont
dits nous ici par le passé
d'abord il y avait la colonisation une
bonne partie sont venus plus être
certain à partir de 1920 mais même avant
aussi certains sont venus pendant la
guerre et ils sont assez bien sûr et à
la création d'ici 50 ans mais bien sûr
ils n'avaient pas pensé qu'après 50 ans
ils seront des étrangers partout
et
depuis dix ans la france n'a plus assez
de bras pour subvenir aux nécessités de
sa croissance est connu alors elle a dû
faire appel à une main d'oeuvre
étrangère plus massif
la france a toujours été un pays
d'immigration en tout cas depuis le
début du 20e siècle
nous avons eu les polonais nous avons eu
les italiens nous avons là pour la
dernière guerre mondiale
nous avons eu les espagnols après la
guerre civile d'espagne
bref il n'ya pas là un phénomène nouveau
la présence des travailleurs étrangers
elle est bénéfique pour notre pays elle
est nécessaire à son développement je
voulais 10 1 million 800 mille
travailleurs qui sont indispensables qui
représente plus de 10% de la population
active
il y a donc là une nécessité économique
démographique aussi mais en même temps
puisqu'ils sont là il faut s'occuper
d'eux
je venais ce qu'on me dise risquant
trois saad eskander nouvelle vidéo moi
quoi je venais ce contrat or mais vivre
il assez marqués 2e à damas car tu as
well as yann marti deuxième attaquant
belge est montré ce que moi je suis venu
en france le 10 avril 1971 j'ai commencé
travail est de 21 avril 1971 mais je me
rappelle ce samedi j'arrivais en france
le premier roi ce tumulte de route 155
je suis arrivé en 1970
je descendais au port de marseille 17
1968 quand je suivais les premières fois
en 61
on n'a rien ajouté oublier d'aller
chercher le travail à ce moment là j'ai
traversé avec la ville d'identité vote
de bergman et base pas mais rien dit
c'est fini avec les cartes d'identité
français journal parce qu'elle abat et
nos amis mais les français musulmans en
algérie
la kabylie région déshéritée par la
nature est aussi la plus peuplée du pays
un dixième de la population voit dans
expatriés de façon régulière pour aller
chercher du travail ailleurs
ailleurs c'est à dire en france où le
marché du travail leur est ouvert comme
à tous les français
alors ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est
que jusqu'en 62 les algériens étaient
soumis au code de l'indigénat
autrement dit étaient des sujets
français et non des citoyens français
ce code de l'indigénat permettait
notamment le déplacement forcé de
population faut savoir quand même qu'on
les recrute et on arrivait dans les
villages on prenait les plus jeunes les
plus costauds on l'êta t on leur faisait
la visite médicale leur ouvrait la
bouche pour vérifier la dentition et
puis on leur donnait un document avec un
tampon peas étaient acheminés par camion
de leur village au port le plus proche
c'est vrai que la majorité effectivement
viennent des zones rurales et que c'est
un choc à l'arrivée ici
au début de décrue et viesly première
fois en 60 kg descendue à marseille
j'avais pris le train jusqu'à rowan
département calendes cet été javier
travail deux ans chez elle à nos usines
qui s'appelle papilles très vif et les
rouleaux de papier je sais par quoi il
est grand volume de jeu comme à saint
ferriol comment vous frayer un
ferrailleur a brillé il ya une fois le
critiquer mois que chaque centime de ces
petits depuis un mois je lui mentais
installe ainsi jamais touché la grise
ios et mon métier à tisser navals
publics
j'aimerais me donner la grille m'a
montré le juste en bas avec la badoit la
combativité comme atterri sur la fiche
commentaires et la balle à six tours à
tati batata bande à 2 3 restants et j'ai
pris l'habitude cei
il m'a réussi dans la grille
je
pour travailler il faut bien donner
satisfaction patron ça tout le monde a
compris ça et le travail que certain
nombre de gens refusent
moi je la prends parce que travail ne
fut jamais peur et je travaillais
toujours en déplacement parce que je
suis déplacé de chez moi puis je
travaille à marseille ou à la bretagne
je suis allé jusqu'à contart jusqu'à 1
brest en déplacement je travaillais très
dur j'étais quand même un anneau h que
dans le bâtiment
j'étais à l'ouest dans le le fabrique de
décès de roger parce que je travaille
une serveuse elles mentent et nous allez
tous à elle à cela que j'étais même
brigade et de trains accrocheur quand
ils ont commencé à fermer 72 ils ont
commencé à fermer des usines en alsace
dans l'amour tout ça j'ai quitté le
lantus très quoi je travaille comme dans
le bâtiment dans le béton l'armée tout
ça
elle
non c'était non seulement beau frère
moment merci bien
dorian sol du monde viennent temps je
lui casse à 20 ans ados on plante le
poteau doué m je veux jours et il y en
existe jusqu'à maintenant des poteaux
vous verrez le poteau de téléphone pour
toi en bois elle peut ton envers on
croit encore à la main rose à la main
ainsi que le barre à mine le père car
est une des 100 âmes et à 40 km à 50 ça
n'est pas la longueur de poteaux le
poteau si m en décembre 30 le 7 mai
drame est à 48 mètres à mettre 50 cent
adoucira 3 à 2 à la main moi que je suis
venu en france je peux penser que je
travaille jusqu'à la retraite
je suis venu en france je pense je
travaille il ya un an deux ans trois ans
après parce que moi je finis après la
bande annonce de l'algérie ce moment-là
fériés pas de travail jeudi après il va
voir le travail que ça j je profite à la
fin je travaille un peu après je
retourne et j'ai commencé ma carrière
là-bas
et comme on a géré il à rester toujours
heures alors je crains qu'il n'y ait
apprécié tout retard quand j'arrive un
certain âge et après c'est fini j p
là bas il personne qui m'embauche
non ça va un peu mieux il a déjà que
tout à l'heure ça va mieux tout à
l'heure 1
parce que les autres et jeanne est non
alors ça c'est quatre fois par jour
c'est pas trois fois par jour -
traitement non ces quatre fois par jour
ont été comprimés quatre fois par jour
second aller un peu trop à 3 tr3 très
pauvre trois fois sur mes quatrièmes
alors là
au début moi personnellement je veux pas
de moi personnellement moi les jours qui
suivent ne contient pas de rester sous
venu pour travailler je mets un peu de
ce côté et je rate mais quand je suis
arrivé à l'aja j'arrive jamais je me dis
de se raconter ce qu'il vous dira poker
en guerre la misère dans l'est pas en
gros les appels à la famille pour vivre
là bas il est peu qui reste pour nous
pour vivre et c'est ça n'a jamais été de
ses côtés jamais
très bientôt ces images appartiendront
au passé
ainsi en a décidé monsieur pierre
sudreau ministre de la construction en
visite aujourd'hui à marseille en
compagnie de monsieur à ce picard préfet
des bouches du rhône de monsieur gaston
defferre député-maire et de tous les
responsables locaux de la première
industrie marseillaise
le ministre a tenu à visiter non
seulement les très rares bidonville de
notre cité mais également tous les
chantiers en cours
notre famille qui sont dedans tout il y
avait plein de bidonvilles little à eau
et en bas et quant au delà il faut
mettre de plastique sur le lit pour que
loïc ça rentre pas dedans et on passe la
journée aux armes parce qu'en disant il
paie le 23 mai 77 ou dans ce premier
dans le balo on travaille toute la
journée et après peut-être 2,3 en grand
format par en bas à marseille et des
douches on prend la 12
je terminais ma
m
j'avais 4 ans ce petit monde naveed
inyat malik haddouk ou 376 6 minutes et
demie pour lui anna diallo duty temps où
il y en a quatre qui tend même à long
terme un autre michael materie
il y a encore des bidonvilles remplacer
petit à petit par des immeubles ne
joueront pas ce qui s'en échappe
ils sont la mauvaise conscience de nos
villes l'image à fanny de la misère du
tiers monde pour le nouvel arrivé c'est
une aubaine l'hospitalité d'un parent ou
d'un frère du même village
vous avez une région
le temps passe et c'est la misère près
du luxe
la bouffe on y rencontre des femmes
effaroucher les enfants beau et propre
des hommes en corvée d'eau le soir venu
shocking famille ni centre culturel ni
logement décent se retrouvent dans les
cafés
la grande maladie qui traduisait dans la
grille parce qu'il est lourd la boîte
l'art et du bâton borghesi la grille
l'église c'est pas automatique ou
maintenant il ya la chaise ya les
manettes on restitue toute la journée de
beau et 10000 la triche par là il vaut
peut-être mieux le caveau en face il ya
4 ko 4 border et j'étais trop fatigué
c'est pour ça la maladie reste images
harbin gong parce que toutes les jolies
suis debout
j'ai choisi le le matador la boîte
l'accueil à des poteaux pour guider la
grille c'est grand comme ça avec un brut
elle quitte le mid 100 de travail nous
avons passé la visite à chanter c'est
lui qui m'a fait réalité il m'a dit
c'est pas normal
tajan milito genre gonflé il avait
angolais au chef de chantier me dit
comment il travaille ça jamais lui
toujours copié comme ça toi toi
eh bien je dis oui très bien mais ouais
voilà ce que j'imagine théologique aller
à paris j'étais en guadeloupe
j'étais un peu barbour aux normes ou le
terme
après j'ai pris le train comme ça ma
maison j'ai trouvé m la place ça
m'intéresse la restauration
sajjadi staline à manger chez moi
alain delon sur vous il y en a beaucoup
pour dorothée dorothée la mange et boit
à l'époque c'est du g20 que bell voilà
mais la fidl événement et je suis j'ai
balle et quand je parle là bas c'est un
jouet algérien l'un je suis re aiment y
crée et quand je reviens ici tu as un
module c'est grand c'est bête mais je
les veux pas le job pas la froisser
j'aime beaucoup la france
combien d une opération 18-18 messieurs
la mauvaise elle ne traite jamais
il a moi pas
ted
lien
m
la ville
autres dates de naissance en 33 le voir
laurent 30 euros le 20 novembre en 33 20
c'est un courriel à la 80ème faisaient
tout qu'ils agiraient qatar va jouer
et oui en 33 ouais ben ça alors je vais
encore vous êtes allés manger je donne
pas bien je pas pourquoi abstrait mais f
pour réfléchir et agir que doit il faut
arrêter de réfléchir un fou rire là le
contre mais ma téloche
voilà c'est vrai
le lire et graver ou berbères les bars
de la ville
j'ai engagé un chaos et à l'armée brazza
là bas au pays à la meyer alors bien
gagner vous ne reverra jamais yvan
d'hématite à weight égalité vendée ils
cherchent sur la vareuse s'était
lourdement wars rabot site où je jouais
50 personnes deux phalanges et moi grâce
à moi il ya joué c'est beau quand j'ai
gagné le gala c'est le projet je voulais
les fictions ils les ont mises en défens
d ajoie pour mourir pour les ormeaux
bon je vous colle je pense à l église
alors l équipage oppose deux voleurs les
violeurs badri réussir et pour trop
laissé à l'ego 13e et contrat vous
parlez l'équipe à l'aube du meilleur
livre à oui moi je te bats c'est la
guerre de chez moi en france mais
qu'elles me manque parce que même nous
était obligé oupeye six nouveau-nés
thuir
on cotise nous aussi aux falaises comme
annabelle somme
j'étais en retard n'a su bac la justice
en ménage avec un burn titre antoine
diot j'ai tiré comme un roi
cette femme mais je connaissais conquête
alors comme il était malheureux cei à 1
à trouver un logement
les gens semblent et oui mais je
travaille à lire travail n'était
rock'n'roll
j'étais jeune mais je me souviens parce
qu'il ya des choses vraiment grave et
gens venus ou français ne vous algérien
je suis content de guerre la violence
ait lieu d'écouté à n'avaient
malheureusement que sans parler de ce
qu'ils ont fait pour les acquis qu'ils
ont envie de nous les français qui les
ont abandonnés mais les algériens qu'ils
ont assassinés torturés
je suis content de ça moi je suis contre
la violence
aubiac
et l'arrière
hélas
on va les six ans après l'indépendance
de l'algérie dans le cadre d'un accord
franco algérien signé en décembre 1968
il y avait une clause qui permettait aux
travailleurs algériens en france de
faire venir leur famille c'est ce que
l'on appelle le regroupement familial
pour en bénéficier il y avait bien sûr
certaines conditions avoir un salaire
décent est stable et un logement qui ne
soit pas un salut
parmi ces chibanis qui n'ont pas fait le
regroupement familial
certains ne comptait pas ré et pour
d'autres il ne rentrait pas dans des
critères demandés les salaires n'étaient
pas suffi malheureusement on peut
constater aujourd'hui que 50 ans après
ils sont toujours là et seul apte à
servir 3,6 à vis tu te dis que il un bal
attendent ça avec six ans par l'abbé sa
famille est mort parce que quand il
était petit nous a littéralement avait
là une nouvelle fois par an ils ont
grandi avec leurs nerfs il y en a ils
n'avaient pas l'habitude de nous voir
tout le temps tout le temps en temps
alors quand ils ces grandes et c'est
pareil
et ça ça leur cuir brut qui disent comme
mon père était là bas une a laissé ici
si iliad avant ma mise en plaisantant on
me l'a dit il m'a dit je n'ai pas envie
que nous un type qui travaille pendant
toute sa vie pour elle pour ses enfants
pour sa famille au dernier moment il se
trouve seul ça fait trop mal très mal ça
fait très mal
j'avais deux garçons à l'époque je
voulais emmener
ma femme est houleux parvenir ben je
dépends faut qu'on vous voulez à la fête
moi je vais je veux vivre en france ne
pas faire vivre ici tout seul
moi je viens de temps en temps une fois
tous les atouts les deux engins et
maintenant va t'arriver d'accord pour
venir
il a compris mais au bout de cinquante
ans à près de 40 ans après j'ai un peu
trop tard parce que j'ai panais et ni
les moyens ni la force de faire ce que
je faisais à l'époque
je regrettais qui se parent estime comme
les autres ou bien j'ai emmené ma
famille si on reste ensemble ici là
parce qu avant moi je dis moi je reste
avec mes enfants et ma femme soit ici
soit là bas là je regarde bien parce que
là j'ai pas profité avec mes enfants
mais maintenant je profite un peu fait
revivre les petits-enfants je drague ce
qui s'est passé vers biarritz n'est mise
à jour interne qui m'a dit m'a dit vos
avis non des enfants ils sont là rien
que ça ça s'est vu des satisfactions
oui ah ouais et encore c'est pas moi qui
l'a si ma femme c'est pas moi mosquée là
ton tour tu pense souvent à ta famille
tu pense souvent à ta famille oui elle
te manque
chaque arrêt magistral et pas celui
d'occuper pas je suis fatigué de cheikh
ahmar
des enfants aux enfants jeux papilles et
malheureusement voyons s'appelle ça fait
ça fait dix ans que je parle tournée on
s'appelle ou et surtout les filles sont
région cet amour pour le papa et les
enfants des petits enfants qui ne disent
pas tout on a besoin de toi ou on
aimerait bientôt voir entamer tout ça ça
fait chaud au coeur
c'était une bonne chose c'est un choix
ne pas voir mes petits enfants et a même
deux qui me parlait des fois au
téléphone pape y attache qui revient y
en a même un qui m'a demandé un droit
d'entrée gigue en train de marchandises
et voyageurs de nos propres
c'est pas facile
son plaisir un petit peu avec ça mais
d'ailleurs je commence à voir l'émotion
quand je pense plus des gens je parle de
ma famille parce que je touche un peu
dans un tissu même vous dire ce que je
touche actuellement le total d'engagés
touche environ 140 euros par mois
comment vous faites pour vivre avec 140
pour l'instant je suis pas facile mais
on fait avec
fausse un crochet rebelles
mais voilà
m
leur famille ils les connaissent tout
simplement par rapport peut être à la
retraite par rapport à l'argentine
ramène par rapport à ceux ce côté pic
lignée que qu'ils arrivent à ramener
chez eux pour pouvoir faire vivre un
petit peu cette famille métro man
autrement
pour eux c'est des étrangers ils vont
chez eux ils ne se sentent pas en
famille ils viennent ici ils se sentent
même rejeté d'abord ne sachant pas lire
et écrire déjà c'est un gros handicap et
ils sont obligés d'aller vers
l'administration plusieurs fois parfois
incompris de ce côté là donc ils
rencontrent énormément de divulguer ce
qui leur pose beaucoup d'ennuis ici
elle passe par là c'est le mot
la rétine et la même somme
zhuzhou matelas
suite
la rue du lion sous votre camp qui si
vous avez 1300 euros
est ce que vous voulez que je vous
rembourse la totalité du brut
non c'est comme vous voulez vous
monsieur comme vous c'est votre cas
c'est moi qui décide quand ils vous
arrivent à atteindre comme ça au départ
alors le brésil
allez vous lisiez à l'autre les
féliciens l'autre par l on se revoit jeu
mais voyez 1000 euros pour son mari m'a
dit m'a moins que bruges jeudi avant 74
ans et je travaille est beau mais
d'élèves des demandes et je dois gazole
et j'aimerais vous avez les suit pas la
tête comme religieux 124ème est si doux
parce que le premier patron là où je
travaille
avant terrain je travaille sept ans et
il me dois de la fiche de paye tout aimé
y avait trois incendies claret et moi
jamais indien maladie pour savoir je me
dois de la fiche de paie il tout il je
passais qu il aussi déclaré
et quand je suis à la retraite
mon plan est distinct vicieux ces deux
voleurs moi je crois que me déclare
ouvrier cité aux prises puis ça l'est
encore plus et que s'ils me déclare et
me dire voilà un plan qui voit là là là
où il les défauts qu'on touche pas la
route à ce candidat parce qu'on prend
pied et en ouvriers c'est pas pareil du
tout à la le monde qui suivit doublettes
mais je ne suis pas venu pas prendre de
travail je suis travailler je suis
ouvrier qualifié ce qui explique la
faible retraite c'est qu'au départ il ne
comptait pas rester
ils sont venus travailler et gagner de
l'argent pour pouvoir vivre et surtout
faire vivre la famille au pays et toute
la dimension retraite et administratives
étaient mises de côté certains n'ont pas
conservé et documents comme les
attestations d'employeur ou les
artifices cas travail et d'autres ont
été victimes d'employeurs peu scrupuleux
mais en france il existe des aides ou
des prestations dont ils peuvent
bénéficier à condition bien sûr de
rester un minimum de temps sur le
territoire français alors c'est le
dernier rappel de la caf avant une
action en justice
la café vous réclame 3660 euros parce
qu'ils avaient fait le contrôle sur
votre passeport où ils ont conclu que
vous êtes vous êtes resté plus de six
mois au pays raconte jamais vaine gspc
moins sonore enfin j'ai dit c'est
sûrement parce que ma femme et les
malades les petites et les malades
alors d'ici six mois par an bouchachi
manger et boire a fait réagir la maison
a commenté s'épanouir mais n'est ce pas
normal
j'ai laissé moi c'est moi c'est moi
c'est moi oui je d'ici six mois si sa
femme malade tu vas rester à la maison
ces deux filets et les démarches bas et
les mois je sais pas quelle magie et
comme l'a fait
donc je vais vous en faire il vous en
fais le le calcul depuis 2010 donc ils
vous demandent de rembourser
l'allocation logement apl que la capelle
vous verse pour 2010 2011 et pour 2012
donc ça fait trois ans il vous réclame
trois ans de l'apn il va falloir qu'on
trouve tous les papiers ça soit du
médecin que ce soit de la cigogne de la
banque
je suis tout de suite on va tout casser
année par année
monsieur cheikh l'oeil de marie un trop
perçu de 15me 480 large
alors vous avez demandé de mode je suis
les quinze mille quatre cent
quatre-vingt onze euros de la carsat
plus les 3660 euros de la caf ont la
retraite et pour laquelle vous avez
cotisé
c'était 323 euros d'accord mais pour
après ils vous ont rajouté une
allocation supplémentaire qui est de 395
euros
cette allocation supplémentaire si vous
partez plus de six mois à l'étranger et
voulant lève 53 j'étais l'homme avant la
guerre
j'ai travaillé j'ai trouvé vraiment je
travaille et je travaille là me jetterai
pas tout demain trois mais je trouve
trois mails ou 3000 à 15 milliards vous
devez 19000 euros
oui déjà donné ses mirage gt
un machin ou bien via son mobile 3g
coûte m
c'est trop trop trop trop trop trop de
se rhabiller
satam en beauté notre non ça c'est beau
les faits seuls les noms 87 15 jeunes
handicapés psychomoteurs sur des
lunettes
son état de santé nécessite un taux
d'incapacité permanente de 100%
oui l'été 2000 tard et elle a été nommée
comme ça comme ça papa tu connais comme
j'ai bâti papa papa partant
le calme et les jolies km
alors les petits déjeuners ont été mis
en place pour les personnes sans abri
qui sont donc au centre d'hébergement
d'urgence
c'est à lui également qui accueille des
personnes isolées et qui est un lieu
aussi de prise de contact avec cette
population
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que l'on
seulement ils ont une retraite mais que
tout le long de l'année on va leur
envoyer un tas de questionnaire où on va
faire des contrôles à domicile pour
vérifier qu'effectivement et nous sommes
là sur le territoire
alors il suffit que l'heureux que la
personne âgée oubli ou ne fassent pas
gaffe une réponse de pannes
questionnaire ou qu'elle ne soit pas
présente à son domicile pour qu'on
considère qu'elle est potentiellement
fraudeurs et on arrête donc on suspend
longtemps la perception a été que
c'était des fraudeurs potentiels kirop
qui arrivent et qui ramassent et le fric
qui repartait dans leur pays
jeudi à rabat à la gare oui j'avais déjà
ramené bougies et j'ai pleuré ça que je
suis heureux et je l'aï et l'avs arrive
à dire je jouis de l'arrière trois
paragraphes
madame la balle j'ai retrouvé ma maman
le tout s'est déroulé les messins ont ce
qu'on nous ait son chantage aux taxis et
que l'on doit pas
la maison blanche s'est tous les
messages
en deux jours
un médecin
allez
mais non
c'est une réserve où on peut stocker
différentes affaires et notamment des
affaires des résidents soient partis
soient décédés mais malheureusement
c'est le cas de monsieur décédé au pays
non on n'a pas connaissance de la
famille en france et donc personne n'est
venu réclamer ses affaires
sauf les papiers les papiers les livrets
de famille les papiers retraite les
relevés de barbelés tout est coordonnée
possible mais toutes ses effets
personnels son nom moi quand je vois ce
chapeau je pense sont résidents mais
pour moi c'est voilà ça c'est simple ça
me fait penser à l'homme à la personne
et voilà six mois j'aurais voulu garder
quelque chose de personnel là et ça
cette demande n'a pas eu de la famille
dans sa chambre qu'il y avait ici c'est
chapeau bien bien placé au mur une photo
d'identité
dans un tout petit cadre et un livre à
lire c'était une vie de guy de
maupassant
je le suis le côté affectent ils avaient
ils avaient parce que quand ils me
disaient si je devais recommencer cette
vie là je ne recommencerai pas parce que
j'ai attendu 14 ans pour entendre mon
enfant me dire papa et quant à une
personne qui vient vous le dire avec des
larmes
un homme d'un certain âge et qui
viennent vous dire ça pour moi c'est
quelque chose de très fort de très
symbolique c'est touchant il ça peut
résumer un peu tout la la solitude la
souffrance
voilà tout ce qui caractérise un peu
ces hommes là
maintenant que ce que je fais ici en
france parce que je ne peux plus vivre
là bas tout le monde est corrompu
et puis la montée de l'islamisme
moi j'aime la liberté j'aime la france
m'a adopté les jeunes m
je rêve en français j'ai moi aussi je
m'exprime en français sauf quand ça
m'arrive de pleurer l'agetur encadré
dennis conner
missionnaire des mesures loser sort
ouais le nombre des délégués de mon
corps
quand il est là bas j'ai vers la plage
effet l'appel jeu comme ici à là bas je
prends du bal des belles pièces et pas
comme ici à des belles pièces parce que
la ville
ça change le 2 3 jours sachant cela je
sais pas qui se vante que ça ça c'est ma
parole et quand j'ai vu la balle
première dix 10 jours ou 15e dj train de
me demander à moi même
est-ce que moi j'étais malade je suis
demandé à maman moi j'étais malade je me
sens pas bien ça je reviens ici on veut
des questions ça recommence là-bas le
diabète génial ce diabétique et un bon
diabétiques mais c'est pas la rigolade
et quand je vais là bas si la nature ou
si la chaleur qu'il fait ça voilà le
thème décembre parce que normal est ici
bien je me suis mise au programme 80
quand j'aurai pas d'accueillir 2 vous
vous sentez mieux là bas quand vous êtes
ici vous êtes moins bien que vous
préférez quand même rester ici ah ouais
moi moi je suis venu seul
je me sens chez moi ici je viens là bas
je me sens étranger chez moi je me sens
étranger mais là je me sens que je suis
moi
lentement
ici on nous appelle des immigrés et
quand on va chez nous soit des gens dans
notre ville n'a pas misé appelle les
immigrés aussi on est toujours émigrés
fais moi enfin trouvé vraiment juste le
lieu va rester au milieu de la mer par
un psg un peu là-bas
un démon
plus je mange pages de leurs pages et je
passe tout mais tu penses à quoi j'ai
pas son mari
on m'a qu'elle était vue comme chine
moi je crois que je le redis temps en
temps je leur raconte l'histoire d'une
chanson de slimane azem qui dit quand je
vais là-bas j'ai envie de revenir quand
je reviens j'ai envie de repartir parce
qu'ils ne sont heureux nulle part enfin
de montres